you can go ahead and click it
right
and then for anybody in chat you
tell us just like testing testing one
two three just for audio volumes how's
everybody sounding if you guys better
stay sensory testing Justin I sound okay
maybe you said five eyes I just reckon
with Chad I do
let us go Chet how we sounding
being fertile says what sounds good to
him
roto rang up smiled oh we did so we good
well grab that final step and we'll get
everything going Oh Morton Aires how you
doing Dakota
shayana doors good afternoon yeah for
those who guys across the pond like
what's up I've been awake for hours
where you been all right well I'm ready
when you guys are so everything
shouldn't be recording 30 frames a
second all right well I'll do my dad
always hold it up for like three two one
and then he kind of takes it over so I'm
gonna let him run the ship to start and
embarrass he was always oh yes everybody
get ready
all right and we all love the last word
with law Cognito any boxes
special campfire edition well we got
going on a made a little special day
there uh gathers there's like
competition trying to come back into
this world we got songs to deal with and
the best part of this is the fact that
we've got an awesome guest coming in
here with us so I'm gonna pass it right
back and let you do it as you always do
sir let's let's who do we got today
well let's get it started man welcome to
the last word episode number 90 it's
another glorious Friday we're back in
front of the campfire but some more
ludus shooter discussion I'm extremely
excited about our special guests so we
gonna get right into it I want to
introduce a lord who is not only
considered a good friend to the campfire
but it was passion for destiny and the
looter shooter genre truly resonates in
every article and every heartache he
shares with it I guess the committee
introducing the renowned science fiction
novelist and outstanding videogames
writer for Forbes calm the Lord of
writing the most progressive changes to
the destiny sandbox yet still the both
fear Lord of suggesting nerfs to budgie
throughout the realm laughs oh hi oh and
making his return into the realm of the
last word mommy
Lord Paul Cassie are you doing sir good
good that lives up to expectations you
set the bar on the first one now you set
your own offe up Cognito you're like
almost you'd already delivered yeah like
I got the nerf Lord with me right now
but everyone's like Paul Cassie's word
is gospel so you gotta be careful what
you say today because bug is hopefully
listening maybe but yeah Jessie do you
think that's hotel like people legit are
in fear when you actually mention
something there might be to be checked a
little bit for Barry if that happens but
like if I mentioning it chances are
Bungie already knows but I mean first
but it's made it across your desk
they're like alright now we got to take
it seriously cuz you know orb said
something so they're serious we gotta
take it serious how you been man been
good been good glad to be on again this
is an awesome show so thanks for having
me back Ben you've been busy sir you've
been if in case you guys haven't been
following this man please follow him on
twitter at paul tas t he is he's all
over the place his face and voices on
many a podcast so if you don't catch him
here you'll be able to find him usually
somewhere probably once a week so he's a
frequent podcaster at this point but we
are lucky to do steel this Friday
morning away got a couple articles out
already and we've got some stuff to talk
about so mmm-hmm we Mills will just jump
right in guys it has been a crazy couple
weeks I was under the weather I will
take the blame last week I was sick I
got my fever / crap kickin all the way
through me so that was finally done I
don't know if you guys have been faced
you guys like make him through this year
fairly unscathed there you guys had
anything yet no I got hit hard too man I
had just
anything about all about a month ago and
it took a long while took about like two
weeks to fight it off so it's going
around so I know you had it I'm like
yeah he's hurt he's hurting right now
that thing's no joke man mmm I've been
lucky this year
knock on wood but you know still winter
so we'll see that often but man when it
does it feels like it's I get it like
every other year and it's like all right
now it's gonna kick you in the face so I
got mine yeah well hopefully I'm good
for a bit but yeah sickness aside what
do you guys been up to and destiny if
you guys been playing the market how's
the stock Street news and yeah it's I
love the community memes and stuff that
have come from this but I can't say that
like I'm personally on the like you must
invest like you know these weeks and
then donate these weeks like I got my
triumph I'm getting 10,000 or whatever
residents a week I do some rolls farming
and then I just keep going like I'm not
terribly concerned about us hitting the
end goal so mm-hmm I don't know I'm not
like a streamer trying to hype people up
so I'm just gonna do it right not that I
blame people for investing cuz like
technically it's the right play to make
if you want like maximum you know rolls
and everything and like then you can
shard stuff or cores and like it's a
good idea it's just I can't I don't care
that much I'm doing other stuff in
destiny not its relative yeah have you
been investing have you been just like
letting the community do their thing
what are you up there I've gotta let the
community do anything selfishly it's
just all about the last thing that was
eluding me was the perfect paradox god
roll which for me is the trench barrel
demolition is roll and I swear to God
eat like they would not give me this
roll so I'm like all right we're just
gonna keep on investing until you know I
get this thing man so literally my
season pass started going through the
roof and I'm shot thick Forte's in the
chat he saw me there and um you know I
just until I finally got that and then
once I got that I kind of just chilled
out I mean all my you know habla stuff
fairly high residence you know pretty
pretty high so I'm just chilling
nice one of those things I feel like
community is going to get there I'm not
you know my my donation it's not gonna
be the single reason why you know things
get to where it has but um doesn't it
pretty much it for me just just getting
that paradox roll I literally got all
the god roles that I want I got from my
martyrs retribution when um when I was
at the anti the whole the one that are
we
yeah autoloading with demolitionist yeah
I've been a huge fan of demolition
everything with me right now is like
demolition is demolitions done
everything yeah like demolition is every
day I want to get my grenades back at
the Sikh solar or warlock build and with
Sun bracers and I'm just I'm loving it
man so everything's going to synergize
with the entire artifact and yeah I
don't think I'd even be I haven't gotten
is the one um I don't got like eight god
world breach lights like liked a see I
don't you've been we gotta get some good
breach lights that's like what I'm store
for guns in the whole game now what's
the role I should go for like I haven't
haven't really use it so pick one okay
so the ones I have our outlaw rampage
LML Chico clip demolitionist vorpal
that's the one I'm using on my hunter
side Arno and then outlaw vorpal it's
for me personally I think it's the one
weapon where four-pole is just like a
must and Lincoln actually does serious
damage to mother it's like maybe that in
the sniper but I don't know like the the
auto rifle and the scout I don't really
think for Apple does all that much even
with the boss effect but the breech
light it absolutely does and and because
it's a sidearm and it hits so hard you
don't really even need like add their in
perks like you don't need really ran
danger multi kill clip for those enemies
so that's why I just slap more people
and pretty much all my my top roles for
it because hmm it's just it clears
everything anyway so I'm glad you said
that because I I need to really stop
sleeping all afforable I've needed to
give it I got a couple of weapons that
I've been like not using and you know
this cuz I think historically usually
little Newport comes out from Bungie
like yeah it's not gonna be that
powerful but you're like the second
person is like no vorpal is it so I'm
gonna give it a shot man got you he let
me know I've got about 25,000 residents
power mm-hmm and I think I'm pretty much
gonna call it there I like I did a
little bit the other like a day or two
ago when it was simulation see
farming day again I was just like I
can't do this now I feel completely
sorry for anybody on console but for
those of us on I don't know if console
is dealing with the same like 25 people
hit the tower at the same time but that
whole tower instancing thing is so much
more abundant now people back and forth
and back and forth oh I'm just getting
so tired that's why I was like I'm done
I'm like 25 thousands good do that for a
few weeks now I just gotta start
donating and kind of going through some
weapon bounties and stuff but I mean I
didn't expect the light and fuse track
the line to do quite what it did for us
to be farming it that way when we all
did the Bree Imperium guides and stuff
like that yeah we have that it's like
hey what are you gonna do well you could
just go crazy like some people who have
like 700 thousand residents they're
never gonna turn all that in their
little stream yes no single button exec
is it'd be like she didn't be an option
for more than 100 per I should there
should be a 400 option for sure your
values and then there should be like if
you just have but tons just like 9 9 9 9
at a time they should like they should
see some of the stuff people are doing
it just like put it put the little other
boxes in there the 400 should be easy
and the 100 should be like that not like
shader dismantle speed yes oh no I
turned it 100 okay mm-hmm like I've
heard people like you know delete entire
stacks of like mods before and then but
you can do this thing slowly so of
course that helped me and then agreed
muster put in 700,000 yesterday yeah
what's the mass isn't it I don't you can
even hold more than like 50 inventory
slots than 20 postmasters how do you
even get up 50 free inventory slots you
can't even some stuff you can't even put
in your vault it's like not even
possible
so like he remembers everything yeah I
got everything it seems ridiculous to me
now this is the big question I wanted to
ask both of you because I have as well
whether we do one or a hundred thousand
or twelve or any
come March 10th is any of this even
gonna matter the community event is is
doing what it's supposed to do like it's
it's energizing the community like it's
raining you're talking about it like
it's a thing like invest donate became
like a whole community thing until I can
get spine in that regard and it's very
rewarding like we're getting just
unlimited rolls and and stuff out of it
so if you miss stuff earlier in the
season with sundial you can get just
endless rolls now and then so it's
rewarding to participate in yeah I think
that we could finish early and then when
we finish will unlock of story quests
we're not gonna unlock like the season
or trials early so like March 10th it's
still gonna be March 10th it's just a
matter of how fast we get to like the
precursor stuff and like these events
are decide not to fail this this is why
they're not telling us what the goals
are ahead of time because if they mapped
it out and it was like way too out there
and impossible they'd be like well you
know what are you gonna do so even I
season I saw there was a Pokemon
community event like a couple of years
ago that were it was like you know we
bought the community capes like 300
billion Pokemon and they did like 8% of
it everyone was like community events
are just are designed to be beautiful so
but it I think it still works for its
purposes here and this feels like a good
kind of feel-good moment for the
community so I think it's been fine yeah
like literally the last last word we did
we had V we had this discussion right
and it was just it was one of those
things that I know I was a bit harsh but
I was like it's free like it's a good
way like don't get me wrong like I love
that we had this discussion before like
I actually love this season for what it
is I didn't I have my expectations in
check you know obviously a ten dollar
DLC and stuff like that I knew we
weren't getting another dungeon I knew
we weren't getting another raid you know
I'm saying but for the story beats and
everything that we got in this whole
thing towards progressing building
trials having Saint as a character who's
an awesome character you know I like
that I'll see I'm gonna start fanboy so
soon as he's back I'm already in it's a
it's a +10 DLC already for me
but you know the whole thing about it
was you know they had to be creative I
felt but you have to be creative and
keeping people invested now I know the
hard core like I will get to this II you
know may be upset with it's not the
Hobby game you can kind of check in and
check out you know just the super
hardcore and get everything done but for
the hobbyist you know this is cool they
can get in and get a couple stuff you
know you got it you had your quest we
had our community events and stuff like
that but back to Imperium you know this
is something I know the community is
going to reach there's no way it's not
happening so again it's just a fun thing
to kind of get people together and I
think this is maybe bungees tactic
during like a post a shadow keep level
drop you know I don't anticipate every
season to be exactly like this one maybe
next season I will have trials I'm
expecting some type of bigger player
activity you know to come but you know I
think we kind of got to expect this once
in a while in this annual past format
there's just my thought process what it
just just based on bandwidth and what
they actually have available to produce
content ya know I mean it's been season
wise that's what one like everybody's
like best lore ever like we've been
chilling what they've done with saint-14
Osiris coming in I'm still curious where
they're gonna leave Osiris in the end of
this thing bold stuff yeah that goes
building the tower like actually doing
an in-game thing to build up the next
season and visually get a representation
of this you know tower and going to
mercury and actually seeing all that
stuff has been cool it's just been
interesting for one this is let I forget
the last time they did this it was like
alright people have too many resources
we gotta suck em dry oh yeah but I gotta
do that so we're back to that one this
is a little less blatant than the
callous tributes but yeah I was like
it's the rewards of the season have been
so much but I think I was like I cannot
remember who I was listening to or what
but it isn't the point of it I want to
ask you guys as we're going through this
it has felt more of a casual season like
as you said pop in pop out check my
ritual boxes like the last three weeks
of the season if I finish up like I got
Python the other day that thing is
awesome
and then I've got to literally just run
some strikes for that one but it's like
if I get that Saviour triumphant we're
just literally like donating crack the
line I'll donate login one day and
there's six days a week I have no reason
to play yeah I mean it does kind of seem
like we are definitely in that waiting
Mon it's not a bad thing obviously he's
in the band with we can't always expect
it but I just kind of wondered as you as
we go through these times of like below
and then we're getting ready for what's
coming
are you just enjoying these breaks or
you're like hey it's kind of nice to not
feel like I'm so connected are you
wishing you could add more of a reason
yeah I'm curious to see how you feel on
that that's actually a question we've
brought up a bunch of times
yeah I've been okay with this season I
went in expecting a light season and I
the fact that these seasons are ten
bucks like to me personally it's like I
think they're under price for how much
you know I've been playing and how much
I get out of it like I got ten dollars
with the content the first two days of
playing like just based on what was
added personally um I don't mind I mean
I'm expecting it to wind down kind of as
things go here and part of it's my own
fault or like I farmed sundial like
really hard I found the battle pass
really hard for the first money so I was
getting you know the four times drop but
the double perks like a month ago and I
got like 95% of all the god roles I
wanted a while ago so I don't really
have anything seasonal to still be
farming however I am using this kind of
downtime to just sort of catch up on old
stuff maybe I haven't done like I just
went back to heroic menagerie and got
all the swords up ahead of the sword
then fan sortable you're a fantastic
sword article shout you out on that one
mmhmm yeah and like I'm upping the sword
changes but we'll make that useful and
like I'm just kind of I'm doing a lot of
old stuff that I just I haven't really
gotten around to like I even grinded
forges for a god role blast furnace that
I never ended up getting so I'm just
kind of taking things that at my own
pace and finishing up stuff in the past
and I know there's like some people that
have like every item every title in the
game but like for 98% of players there's
always something to do if you really
want to I think if you don't play other
games like I'm playing I'm playing
Borderlands I'm going to do the division
thing like it's okay like it you don't
need to be playing destiny every single
day with like brand new content and if
you really if you want to you can
like there is enough stuff to farm where
you can theoretically do that but we
can't you can't expect like a new story
mission a week you're like mm-hmm a new
raid every season like it's just it's
not gonna be like that I agree I'm so
glad you said that because I you know
I've been on that training and listen
you know of course I love you know the
shadow keep level type dry and stuff
like that but again I have to be
realistic and you said it you said it
good it did sense that like you know for
the amount of hours I've put into this
game especially this season and and you
know it's been a lot
you don't say interests that we're
hardcore were you star even more harder
grunts I can't legitly get mad and say
you know bungee this is you know say
this is terrible or this is that when
I've put that a munch amount of hours
invested you know the saying so I think
what it is is I understand that top 2%
or 5% of whatever it is that hardcore
base who may be frustrated either saying
but these things for me there's things
to do you don't say and in the way I
look at it is if you've gotten
everything out I say for example you're
in your situation tastic where you got
that season pass the extra you know
perks for the god roles you know you did
you the ritual weapons you did all that
stuff it's okay to step away for a
little bit it's it's okay you know I'm
sayin and to me and I know we'll get
into it as far as what's going on with
the other Luther shooters and stuff like
that and we got outriders division two
and even that anthem to talk about you
know I'm saying I'm actually in a cool
place with it you know I'm saying as
before when you know I just can't I
can't justify getting into this rage
that how dare they like I need to be
praying there's 40 plus hours and like
I'm just not at that level I kind of
cringe when I hear people say that when
you have Plus you know a zillion hours
in the game but you're mad if you can't
play you know plus 50 hours a week or
whatever it is you know I'm just not
there but were you at E but this whole
cuz it's been pushed back with the
community we've been seeing it I mean
I'm with you guys to the point of like
this is felt like hell I'm even like
season ranked 130 and I still feel like
I've been ultra casual this season like
I said I just did like Python I'm like I
did the dawning farm cells like I want
to get 19 who just knocked out so that
was done and then I've casually just
been doing other stuff but I felt like
probably as casual I've been on a season
in quite a while cuz
there hasn't been that much I've been
like either work has been a little crazy
just a combination of things but even
and then I still don't even feel like
I'm that far behind
yep because like if you make it through
I feel like I've checked all the boxes
I'm almost done and I'm just here
looking at these last three weeks and it
was honestly debating I'm like hey like
what are the game could I play for like
three weeks while I wait mmm and
honestly get that like just that fresh
perspective when you come back to it if
you don't play destiny for like three
weeks you come back and be like yeah
this game still feels good like every
time you come back from something it's
nice to get that refresher and I think
is what you're saying some of the ones
that do live and breathe this whether it
be I mean it may be a job it may be
twitch it may be something where they
have to go to a point but it is like
those couple weeks away sometimes is
something they need to get little
perspective when you pick up that do you
fire your Tatara gaze and you're like
dammit that gun feels good like haha
some of those still feel like and when
you said that blast furnace god roll
there's a reason I still have my go
figure is cuz I don't have that law you
and the Damned and it's been forever but
I got it
but oh also I didn't I oh be lab so like
I doing like really like really random
like I didn't there was no reason to do
that but I did a couple of my buddies
and it was fun like it was you know look
at you if you're looking for a challenge
and the season they know anything
challenging like go back and do
something like that you've never done
like it's not there's always stuff
salute to the bender with the sub e yeah
yeah it's like that's kind of what the
season has been is like it's actually
been nice to give us time and I'm kind
of curious how the pacing of say this
season feels cuz lake I mean we had
shadow keep we had undying on diagnosed
small or shadow keep us big rent this
felt like hey we we jam-packed this one
might be a little lighter I'm curious
where the spring actually hits for
season size and stuff because that's
that big six month cadence from a big
release so that's like that half a year
marked I'll be curious to see how big it
is in comparison yeah absolutely
absolutely
well we also got some changes coming
next season's viewing up as we go into
spring I know definitely something you
and I probably could come is very about
four hours of on armor 2.0 for sure
there Paula we've had some issues and I
still and even and I was like I want to
kind of let it to you first I read your
article this morning I want to hear
kognito and then I kind of get into mind
but we have changes coming garmr 2.0 in
season of the worthy since that cat is
out of the bag um but elemental affinity
is actually gonna be able to be changed
and reading yours I got a little bit
more detail on like the cost of the
upgrade which actually I had linked lion
steady yesterday and then also seasonal
mods being a little more flexible
between like undying dawn worthy quote
whatever's next I love her they say
redacted but we're just going worthy no
of course uh
so I wanted to get you guys thoughts cuz
on the article just the fact that we're
able to change infinity next season the
mods being a little more useful just
wanted to see your guys thoughts on that
I know you've wrote an article so if you
want to summarize it you can but yes so
like fundamentally they're good changes
I think armor is still in kind of an
awkward position because you know the
question is like okay if you're gonna
make affinity changeable like do we
really even need affinity at all and
isn't just kind of another currency sync
but I feel like with the way destiny
works if they were like okay we're
removing affinity that would mean like
okay now you have to reform all your
sets because we can't just like flip the
switch and turn it off because that's
generally how the game works
um this example I think this is a good
compromise I guess based on the way
things work now because so no I can't
just flip over my entire master work set
the solar because if you could do that
for just like five enhancement cores
essentially there's there'd be no reason
to ever farm armor again like what if
you had this the set you want the stats
you want like you the highest stats and
the right distribution there would be no
reason to find any alternate sets really
because then in any context you could
just flip it over for really cheap so in
theory you still want to at least find
like three like you're trying master
work like three sets of different
affinity armor that you're comfortable
with and then I think if anything is
really good for exotics because
yes you know who hasn't seen an exotic
drop you're like uh it's like a 64
amazing and then like oh it's arc like
no but in that case it'll cost you
pretty much nothing to change it it'll
just cost you an upgrade module and so
like now I can make my tricks leaves
actually have sidearm reloader which
roll my oh this is sidearms it doesn't
have any with it sorry guys like look
I'm recording a video and so now that's
kind of a problem in the past the
seasonal mod thing is is interesting I
think it's even more confusing and I'm
still not even 100% in this solely I'm
hearing that the current obelisk mods
are going to be available next season
mm-hmm and you'll be able to use
whatever the new armor is and slot those
mods like obviously I think they have to
leave the obelisks and like you'll have
to be able to earn them some other way
but I don't think those are going away
which is something I'm kind of assumed
would happen all season right because
it's tied in to seasonal content but
someone pointed out to me like temporary
mods are like green artifact mods and
then these mods are gray and like that's
like the sign of a permanent mod so I'm
wondering how that's all gonna work and
then they're talking about like okay you
can use mods from the season before
before or either so it hits before it
has to be like those have to be sticking
around or else that description doesn't
even make sense so yeah that's kind of
cool if we're gonna get those charges
like mods and then maybe some new charge
with like mods and worthy that could end
up creating a lot of cool builds in it
that the catch is that the further away
you get you are gonna start ruling out
some of your past sets because yes you
think it's not a permanent well yeah
because they said these season
immediately before and immediately after
so once we get to the season after
worthy your dawn armor with that slot
won't work on whatever those mods are
that's a shin that I don't know that so
it's not that we've gotten down a window
lot gotcha okay but at least the window
is not just one season now it's like
yeah to to them it's like two seasons
mm-hm
so I just like it just says during the
seasons before and after it doesn't say
like I don't know how distinct they go
before and after cuz I mean I I saw
Cosmo clarify so so he did yeah was okay
for sure
so so when you get to season 11 you will
be using undying if that's what I would
that be right yes I lose track of the
numbers but yet whatever the season is
after worthy yes yeah mm-hmm how I
interpreted it I will see it could be
different but I think that's how it is
and so like that's I guess I understand
that too
because like it's another reason they
have to keep thinking of some reason to
grind Armour and to date it was just too
restrictive with affinity and the
seasonal slots lasts a season because by
the time you grind it up any set and
it's the next season and then it's
obsolete and like I spent two months
master working the set yeah so if it
didn't work for any new models and
worthy that would hush but now it's very
easy once so that's better for each yeah
man yeah I mean I'll jump in yeah I mean
this was this was pleasant I mean this
is you know for me I was actually
surprised we got it this fast to be
honest you know I know you know
community's been complaining but I've
been fast yeah I mean no I was like I
think people complained about this since
almost like week one so as life and six
months later is like I don't know their
development cycle time on that but I was
like this getting a season so all the
stuff we complain about none dying gets
fixed at the end of the day you know I'm
appreciative of it it is something that
was looming you know having that that
investment in Armour and then like like
Paul said you get to the end of the
season and you're just like why even
bother because this is gonna become
useless right so now we have that home
before and after window so that gives us
a little bit more time as far as
investment I love that aspect and to be
honest I'm actually surprised at how
cheap the actual affinity change is so
you know just an upgrade modular I was
like wow like that's pretty it exam for
bright dust that's all you guys
weaknesses but that's over I stopped out
I've turned over a betel leaf now I'm no
longer doing that you gotta kill me
though I thought that was cool you know
that was huge and then um they said we
got that going on with with the mods and
stuff like that this is this is a good
change and I'm saying this is something
that is definitely needed and we're just
not getting rid of armor because that's
bottle thing you got these crazy
rolled he's good you know quit me and
then you're just thinking it back your
head I'm not gonna be able to you know
utilize that so you know the question I
have though I don't know if I've missed
this so you guys can help me out
um well we use this upgrade module to
change affinity is it going to be like
orangey or is it a direct path or you
can tune also it is a direct path / okay
okay so I could say hey I want you know
my exotic whatever to have Ark you know
affinity oh well it'll be like a
drop-down and you can pick from the
other oh then you can pick from nice oh
okay I thought they were gambling that
would be okay that would really really
be a shot in the face because I I was
happy with I didn't even think they
would be this generous I thought they
were gonna glass needles 2.0 us you
gotta hit the slots today you like big
money boy a coin flip yeah exactly said
I don't do a good at route but uh
thankfully they did the right dig I will
say the two things left for armor from
my perspective if we're know feels like
a racing affinity is more sources of
ascendant shards and I believe that's
gonna come at least from trials I have
to believe trials will reward the sender
charts I'm hoping they do something like
a legend reset or something mid crucible
gives you a shard that would be it I'd
be so I want bourse the gambit somehow
or sharks just about a little more than
like running nine eighty nightfalls
infinitely like that's exactly like a
good is we need more sources of high
stat drops and like I have to believe
that's coming to like it's crazy that
there's pretty much to sort it's like
iron banner sometimes raids exotics and
then if the season pass gives us another
heist at set of armor but like it's
crazy that I can go the entire season
and I didn't find one piece wider than
the entire heist at set in in the battle
paths so Wow even if it's a lower chance
for like more random activities they
really got to bring that up because it's
point it's pointless to grind for like
EP armor as much as I like that armor
it's never gonna be as good it's the one
I have so right they gotta be a little
more generous with those stats yeah I
mean that's pretty pretty much on that
south to see free sale of the changes
but he said they hope they continue to
make contact where content where I feel
it's even useful to use these mods for
yeah that's my only thing with D what
does it did what's this current margins
like charge the fight
yeah I'm not there with the charge but
like stuff to be honest you know I
messed around with it a little you know
I mean there is some synergy with
certain things that are that is okay but
I'm not it at a whole like really
invested in that aspect so I wanted to
get your guys thought on that and then I
shot the Forte he mentioned that on the
upgrade module you have to add energy to
it the energy doesn't transfer with the
switch so I'm assuming you still have to
make an investment in some type of what
material stuff with high energy um this
is just the cost of like whatever you've
put into the armor you'll have to put it
in again if you switch oh okay so is it
so it goes back to almost like a default
big either it's gonna reset to one and
enough to reinvest or to make the switch
entirely it'll cost like the grand total
I think of everything you spent so that
could be that ship president are sharp
young yes fully master worked so you're
testing like where you at with the whole
season my like if I charge with light
stuff it's usually the stuff the problem
with that a lot of that was based on
affinity
cuz I so with all through my characters
I picked the void affinity set and I
master worked as much of it it's like I
could and then I didn't use really any
other legendary armor so I was only
using the void affinity charge with
light mods and then of those because a
lot of them are so expensive and some of
them are very situational really the
only one I use is become charged with
light when picking up an orb and then
whatever the protection from the void so
when your shield breaks you get like a
ton of damage protection for like eight
seconds or something I found that to be
very useful however
affinity thing I didn't use any of those
and like I know you can do like some
like shotgun builds an infinite Ambo and
that's that's cool but like I didn't
have a good arc set to even play around
with that more and then a lot of the
other ones I a lot of the other charged
with light mechanics or it's like
getting rapid sniper headshots or like
using finisher that costs 10 percent of
your yeah like any any mod that requires
super I don't use unless it's like very
situational to get special ammo or
something but so I just I didn't use
those and then a lot of the other ones
that aren't the damage protection one
costs like four five six energy and like
even in a matte fully mass or a piece of
armor which is not in the given for most
people like I just don't really have
room like oh do I want to eliminate like
my recovery or my load more like there's
not enough space like I've been on the
mind that I think we need at least
either costi to come down and where we
need at least five more slots in like
caches of armor cuz I don't think
there's enough to make as many
interesting builds as we could otherwise
based on how much things cost currently
cuz the trade-offs you have to make are
just not enjoyable like I don't like
killing my stats like to make room for
some specialized and a mod stuff yeah
there's this 1-20 mobility or whatever
it's gonna be yeah it's also gonna cost
you like five energy in your thing in
the five unless you just masterwork that
thing a lot of people aren't even gonna
want to go above seven if they are not
spending currency so you've got a whole
bunch people not even yeah most people
don't have the shards so like everyone's
like cap seven like if that they can
spend the cores and that's you know
you're using sixty seventy percent of
your thing just on one mod per slot so
mmhmm yeah that's kind of my biggest
thing of all the like Esther Cross had a
good video about charge with light and
just the same thing I think everybody's
been thinking it's like it's decent in
theory but I guess you said it's too
costly like those should all be maybe
one just so we can all toy around with
and then maybe if you want to keep that
stuff around and season worthy hey we're
adjusting the cost of these things
let us like play with them a little more
when you want to experiment with this
whole like season of the experiment with
like they artifact in those mods and
stuff like that if you're gonna bring
new mods in don't make them so costly
that nobody wants to try them and then
you serratus down I would say much less
try that as a lower as you're saying at
the lower cost may give us more energy
on the armor which
whichever one's easier to program I'm
guessing the cost numbers probably
easier for them to fix at this point but
yeah yeah I think I think I mean just to
push back a little I think honestly you
know it's it's like I always say it's
daddy Bunji balance man they're always
worried I feel on they're always on the
cautious side of trying it with bills
and breaking stuff they want to give us
flexibility but at the same time they're
like okay we're not gonna let them ok
max out five intellect and go all out
with whatever new perk you know that may
synergize with it and I think that's why
you get a lot of these insane cost
prices for certain things you know and I
think when you look at something like
the artifact they're trying to tailor us
towards a certain bill they're trying to
tailor us towards you know solar or
whatever they try to tailor us towards
using Scouts and linear fusion rifle
enhanced loader Maya may enhance you
know aim assist my unflinching might be
like only plus two because they're
trying to you know skate us in that bill
so I just think it's their way of
control yours they like like and that's
that's fine too any of them trying to be
like yes they they think they know but
also how many times Telesto broken I
mean we had Don blaze he like all like
there are times this game occasionally
breaks and like if they wanted to when
Luke and Mark made their big speech they
want to be like hey we want to embrace
this you know massively mom like the MMO
RPG piece of it anything about any of
the other stuff we're getting ready to
talk about when you think about builds
and stats and this is where my piece of
this comes in it's like if they want to
get a little deeper into it
I want the stats to mean more I want
these mods to have a little more
versatility and builds like we are still
a guardian but like if you just honestly
if you take like somebody who's pretty
skilled like taking esoteric I could
give him any build any trash set of
armor that's at a reasonable level and
he he can go do pretty much anything and
not everybody could do that but right
there's a point where you probably
shouldn't be able to do that because
your gear is not where it should be
you're not Specht out for the right
thing
okay those like whether it's like have
stats that mean more I still wish like
resilience actually made you stronger
it really doesn't it does it like that's
one of those things that bugged me
coming from everything I've ever played
is and it's like my brothers
way and we'll just like riff about this
like world of warcraft lake it's not
that game I'm fully aware but Diablo
like a barbarian and a caster you don't
even wear the same armor much less have
the same amount of health you have like
a mana shield versus health and that
stuff works differently and I know we're
not gonna take destiny there but I still
would like to see resilience like my
joke would be like take like you have
four people on a team for hunters that
are faster but to Prime's of titans that
could tank the four hunters and then
they could like mess with each other and
that way it's like an you could actually
have stats that matters all I'm going
for like I know all the stats are a
little weird like mobility I can make
sensor unlike yeah you should move
faster probably all the time not just
80s but resilience you should take more
and some of the other abilities for
there but like even when it comes to
just the stat rules that we have now but
what I'd like to see them start getting
a little bit higher as we go into future
seasons given us resin to like instead
of a cap in it like 65 66 like what we
have in the season pass start creeping a
little higher okay so you want you up
push back because you want more
distinctive changes on like the
resilience thing or just a clown just
overall you feels like that's just like
I think you are you feeling a good
powerful enough that's my question I
guess my mom
I don't usually I feel like II feel like
I do anything I don't matter that yeah
yeah mmm-hmm like I could have like
tails right matters a lot more than
mobility and resilience like I say just
made it cost more for the mod so like
adds just better like you know yeah
that's a good way to counter it as
opposed to the city I heard was
resilience like gives you reduced flinch
or something like that was a good okay
but fundamentally yeah it's just it's
just those stats and then
everything else is just like cooldown
timing essentially and yeah that's not
yeah it's fine but that's always been in
the game like just cuz there's it's on
the screen now like that was that we had
grenade mods and melee mods before so
that's not exactly new um so I think
that's why stuff like charged with like
mods that at least do interesting things
that aren't necessarily stat focus are a
good idea but ro they've got to figure
out a better way to implement them and
get people using them like I have a
buddy who raids like you know 9 times a
week and like he plays tons of PvP and
my kit legend and that's all this stuff
I had to explain to him what charge with
light meant like yesterday did he
handled in it because it's not on his
radar and like bunchy just doesn't
really it gets so hard even like get a
charge with light builds setup for most
players that people just don't even
bother so right do you think Paul it is
it is it also a situation do you think
where bungees not doing a good job of
like say for example the obelisk were
they when they'd be right here I watched
a video and we saw that each obelisk had
the specific you know builds and
specific minds and stuff like that do
you think the situation they're just not
ingratiating that to the player to help
them understand or just encourage them
to utilize these things you think
there's anything they can do to do that
well you just think Mattie Giants is
just kind of semi trashing like where
you're at with the you know bungees
introducing it and trying to get players
to utilize it I mean destiny is on the
boarding process has been pretty
terrible for a while well the new light
off is very bad yeah yeah those like you
jump in you're like hey here's gambit
well do I know all the mechanics of
gambit when I click on a button on the
internet gambit tutorials I just never
put it out but I was trying to go in
just like you can go through what's the
gray bar mean like unguent Oriole match
I'm not saying that be the easiest thing
for them to build but like take somebody
through ace you can do a private match
of gambit and all by yourself and you
can actually see the mechanics and just
like hey you want to do this hey here's
a tutorial private match we're gonna go
through explain and pause the game for
me like hey this grey bar means the
other team has this going or whatever
all in the means those type of things
the same way it's like hey would you
unlock your first obelisk mod maybe
there's a little pop-up or the next time
you come
one of the things that doesn't like when
you look at the screen wrong disappear
you guys are talking about they're like
yeah you're like I moved the cursor know
what's gone what'd it say like I hate it
with no way but actually have one this
pops up or an obliging like a tooltip
something over that saying hey this is
the system you're gonna get a charged
with light here's this little buff down
here when you use it it's I mean when
you think about it yeah it's pretty
logical but what there's a whole lot of
people that don't know I don't know
whose tweet I said but it's like
somebody was like why are so many things
in this game so hidden like yeah so not
obvious somebody said it yesterday and I
was like I know totally true it's a good
point and again I'm gonna push back also
which you would pause for us like so we
really think it's like more of an
onboarding issue this is still getting
people familiarize with what they're
supposed to be doing and how new
mechanics work you you agree like Paul
what are you at with that it's bull I
think I think something like apps will
set for charge with light would have
been a good idea
I didn't mind personally how it was
presented in diabolos like it the game
makes it pretty clear that the obelisks
or the main point of the season and they
give you you know screen for each of
them and like all these different things
that you get when you rank up so that's
right that presentation is is okay with
me
I think Mart of it is the onboarding
where they don't really explain charged
with light after that it's just gonna
have to read each individual mod and
then be like okay like then think about
it I think the other half of the problem
was the current issues with armor in
terms of people just not like not really
having the slots to play around with
those mods and then so not mothering and
also not really having the challenging
content that requires any of those mods
to form some sort of build and you
couldn't be you know that's very
beneficial in certain activity right and
so like and then the affinity thing so
like if you have one set of armor you're
using you're not using two-thirds of the
mods they invented I can't even name any
of the solar mods like I don't as much
as I played the season I just haven't
looked at them at all because I've been
playing with these void sets so mmm I
think it's a combination of those things
in terms of like why people aren't using
them in addition to maybe some some
level of an onboarding thing but I think
it's also a lot more than that - yeah
the last point I'll make is just that I
I completely both of you and I think
that I think for me another thing that
would help is you know we kind of looted
to is like when we talked about that
pinnacle level content for example like
legendary sundial right I think maybe
one cool thing is like like when they
introduced um anti barrier champions all
that stuff right at that point we
realized okay if we don't have these
mods on our weapons we are not defeating
these enemies right so maybe something
similar with the Charter lot of mod
stuff or maybe add that to a harder
level content and say okay this is a
prerequisite you know to beat set boss
you know guys need to be charged would
like to break out a shield or whatever
it may be so this way it's kind of
encouraging people okay I need to kind
of use this stuff or otherwise I'm not
gonna be able to beat the content I
don't know how you guys feel about that
but I do feel like yeah they still have
to do a better job of getting people to
kind of utilize this kind of stuff
because it's just unexplained yeah
unlike champions stuff it's all fully
optional like there's nothing nothing in
the game that requires you to be charged
plate like some of the some of the mods
are helpful and fun hmm but there's
you're never gonna be forced into using
them for any syntax in the current state
of the game you can say I but and I
think that's been good for champion it's
like I think it's good to have this kind
of new challenge and then okay here's
the new challenge and here's the new
system we came up with to overcome that
challenge and like that was a pretty
clear and I didn't wear as charge of
light it's just it exists it exists yeah
why yeah I mean this is the first season
of it so I and they've said that
sticking around so I think they'll be
able to evolve it and grow it over time
and more and more people will get used
to it
um so I'm hopeful that it could still
end up being useful but as for why it
didn't really work this season I think
yeah yeah no doubt no no back to you
yeah no I mean just to wrap all that
stuff up I'm with you guys for sure when
it comes to all of those things if I
could like to see a little more
onboarding a little more reason to use
them I don't know if I want to
specifically be charged to light to face
a boss mm-hmm I was like in theory
buzzing lunging is already useless
enough
true but I shot the legend oh try shout
out the lay hold on we never talked
about this last week come on in Oh Tim
that was a good fight yard I was doing
was it wasn't the undying it doesn't
like have to you with legend difficult
I'm just talking about being here me to
get it me to get a chance to talk about
cuz we always complain like you know
everyday was say me as far as the boss
stuff yes I'm just talking about no such
a boss fight that I'm sad if it just
goes away in a month
yes appearing kind something again I
agree a strike bus but I agree and then
be awesome yeah I completely agree now
to your guy's point even though it was
cool you know there needed to be some
drops associated they needed to be
something else to really just put that
ribbon on the top so make you make us
continue because literally I just did it
and I'm doing it for my was my savior
title and I really know it there's no
incentive for me to go back in there
oh it would have been don't one pinnacle
drop yeah that's it like one pinnacle
jar and then the clinical trials no
matter the sad thing is they're all
weapons you have no way to get armor
from that yeah so like if you have three
962 like if you just say your line 16
you've been doing them which we have
three 962 weapons from like Iron Man
this you're like that's all I have I
only have 960 two weapon like I haven't
done anything
the exact same boat so then I go in
there I'm like there's no reason to at
962 because I need one more piece to
even make it matter I can't even do that
there's no point for pinnacle drops at
all this season content that's hard
enough to require you to be like level 9
90 or whatever yeah see the people look
thousand I'm like you are a man to me I
mean like plus 20 from the artifact just
from all these bounties alone like
that'll turn it like the weapon bounties
give you a ton of XP so like mmm I've
gone up like four power levels just just
from fractal eeeeenh bounties you can I
mean especially for doing perfect
paradox cuz it's like that would be
seven if it's for her you know whatever
so it's yeah that's pretty funny
mmm that's literally what I was doing I
just blew through yeah my mom I pass on
that level absolutely it's been kind of
insane but yeah yeah like even thought
was a really cool fight but again it
says they I think a big thing is the
rewards of these like giving us a legend
difficulty but there's no real reason to
go do it nothing unique there's
even a specific set of couple guns in
there there's nothing there's nothing
really there's no you know heroic
menagerie has a swords which was
something had is a nike catalyst the
catalyst they got to do a better job
with pinnacle content again we
understand that the the light chase kind
of doesn't matter as much but if you
give people incentive with great weapons
or cool armor or unique drops that can
only happen in activity then we'll form
it but other for right now it's like
they still missing the boat when it
comes to these level activities and I
really hope they change because we all
agree the content we felt the you know
the heroic fight was a good encounter we
thought the mechanics were cool it was
different it was unique you know I would
pleasantly surprised not to see the same
level mechanic that we saw with the
other two you know scion players
whatever so it's not vex offensive like
2.0 yeah god yeah it wasn't like it's me
again just a different skin and now they
would sell it's not pretty quick exactly
be like okay somebody build a boss thing
we got like a month for it to get there
so we're gonna base and do that
absolutely yeah no I think I'm just with
you guys though it's just like where I
want to see the rewards fixed yeah when
it comes to the endgame type stuff if
you're gonna make something difficult
make it worthwhile
other than or don't do it and of one of
those type situations because it doesn't
seem to be worth it so we will save
but yeah so I mean that's a giant
discussion that fell off of seasonal and
our Mermoz but you guys want to touch
anything there for affinities or
seasonal mods or anything else on that
you guys pretty good there article there
we got iron banner coming again just
after crimson days back then I was like
I was doing really well for like the
first hour and I got some hard so I'm
like alright and then they rolled it
back I'm like I don't care I already
have the bow I don't care anything else
say but I was gonna say boy like what's
the first thing I did I was like alright
let me see let these rewards talk about
I'm like I got that ball ready so I'm
just like the example did ya the exact
same bow I'm like alright I did not care
about the the word cliff coil ornament
it de sparrows with not it was just no
incentive for me to do it and what's
funny is I don't you know I like PvP I
actually don't mind
crimson days as a mechanic as a to play
I think it's a great mode yeah I
actually like it to stay in a partner
Allah I remember playing it for the last
couple of times it you know last couple
times he came around and having fun
doing the mold but I looked at it I'm
like I am NOT doing this for these
things they they they're it's not
happening so Shaq's I didn't even go get
your bounties I left you in your
confectionery hearts all alone nothing
I'm a very bitter single person in the
feeling love bad about that in develop
that's easy to do any of that II
well yeah bit about being too hard on
this enough I'm the same boat if you've
been around before and you got the foul
unless there's one of those cosmetics
that speaks to you and you've got a
bloody bill you can go run a nightfall
in a couple crucible matches and be
pretty much good to go
cuz the nightfall I will say I'm glad
they implement a little PvE stuff to it
yeah and I was cool that was like it it
was nice to see some of the bounties and
other things are not specifically
crucible related so that was a nice
refreshing people think they are though
that people think you have to get like
twenty melee kills in crucible so
they're like
around doing that when are you doing I'm
like you just go to a lost sector dude
punch away mmm
yeah so that was a nice little addition
because it's been very PvP focused
before I will say for the matches that I
did play which were not many I played
like it's a 5.3 were free downtime and
then I played a couple more when it came
back up I was like yeah I'm kind of done
because the two I played when it got
back up yeah I can I think it's Chaplin
for I want to say and it's like a round
point beat one pair was inside we were
outside and it was on the ground so it
wasn't gonna end and we were just like
trading her needs back and forth in the
hallway cuz if you sit next to each
other they spawn so fast it was like
Roger bounced mine around the corner
they're throwing their scatters and
we're just sitting there at a stalemate
and we're like nobody's gonna move
we threw grenades from probably like 30
seconds constantly in that doorway and
then finally is just like screw and I'm
gonna go die so it's funny that's what
it turned a lot into was the but I mean
the twos is cool cuz like if you split
you see each other you gotta stay
together
mmm-hmm I didn't mind I don't mind the
variety I never do it's nice to have a
little difference and the fact that this
is only up every so often is like mm-hmm
got a cool would be nice to see a little
more in the rotation alright I'm
wondering why they can't why couldn't
they just give us random roles on the
vowel-like it seems so weird to have it
curated only a curated prize like I
guess maybe that would have required
testing they didn't want to do but like
yeah you know rapid hit rampage rapid
hit explosive you know I would have farm
for that but mmm-hmm what about you man
turbo that we still haven't seen our
bows really that crazy that they're
afraid to break something something we
don't know but let's get to the elephant
in room like let's be real between iron
banner and and now you know Nicole
Crimson days ding how are we in this
weird place where there's just no again
like a unique weapons or like we haven't
got anything to really grind these
activities or when they come around you
know and I'm just curious on on that
whole thought processor or is it just a
bandwidth thing we just have time to do
it or like it's just very weird to me
that crimson days comes it's the same
exact reward for the most part outside
of that you know the two people you know
the Batman and Robin's buggy
you know what are you in the sidecar Pig
but you know it's just like I just don't
understand it what do you think is going
on taxi like wait wait
to be fair crimson days has always been
fully useless like it's true it's it's
always the most useless event every year
iron I mean iron banner just didn't need
to exist this season like it it existed
for the sake of existing but with nook
with no new weapons and then just
another armor set that you had to
relearn for the third time I think like
there's no reason to do it other than
maybe clinical jobs but as we've covered
there's no point pinnacle drops the
season so I played I think I got one
armor set on one character the first
iron banner and that that was that I was
done and there's just there's no reason
to do anything else I think this
would've been a pretty good season to
implement maybe the beginning of an iron
banner title so at least people and
something to grind for it for that man
and obviously you know we're heading
into trials and so whatever is all the
boring PvP so that's happening now and
there's no weapons to farm for I my
guess is they're using the bandwidth to
make trials weapons and trials armor and
the yeah that's probably why they're not
doing really anything with PPP now is
because it's small being sunk into that
for next season and like that's a whole
other can't afford me so we can get into
but that's a small area that's a good
point that's a good point and in that
you know not if you put it that way I
I'll calm down because obviously bees
had this discussion with me
and he knows how emotionally I get about
trials and how I wanted to be perfectly
we had a good episode we at him but you
know one of the things that you know he
said he was like okay if it comes back
you know you know how does it need to
come back and I was telling him about
the aesthetic I was telling about the
rewards I was talking about all those
things
so I will say this II you know to
Tassie's point that if crimson days and
all these things that we're suffering
now results in that bandwidth being put
towards trials again cuz my whole thing
with trials is there's never gonna be a
good time with the meta matt is always
gonna be with you know funky it's always
going to things that change whatever
whatever but if you have those great
rewards if you have those great look
that great armor that great incentive to
keep playing this content over and over
again that's gonna be the key cuz I
think the mode is fun itself you know
I'm saying you know three three
elimination you know it it sells itself
from an activity standpoint but you got
to get people the incentive to keep
doing set activity over and over and on
with these great rewards so that's what
I'm really praying open that everything
is really going hard and that and
they've had so much time let's be honest
right trials has been away so long like
there's really no excuse for a subpar
incentive reward system kind of thing
that's just where I met your happy man
because that's where I'm with I'm with
you it's like I think it's until we see
it until like all the community this is
like oh please be traveling be in it
doesn't like hit the nail directly on
the head and I'm worried man this'll
have to be lenient and like I am one of
the biggest thing I'm concerned about is
that Bungie is gonna deliver on all like
its sick trials armor sick trials
weapons and like they do know that and
then you're gonna have 90% of the player
base being like whoa I can't you know
I'm losing after two games oh you get
any of this stuff and then we stay out a
whole debate again and then you're gonna
see people be like well this is the PvP
season there's nothing for me the PvE
player boy get any of the new cool stuff
and like yeah
I just know that debate is coming and
like oh yeah there's someone who isn't
like amazing at PvP like I'll play
trials but I'm probably not gonna unless
I'm carried I'm not gonna get like all
crémeux rewards and stuff so like it's
it's kind of hurts a little bit but like
I understand why this I used to exist
because we've gone so long without you
guys a vehicle PvP rewards that money
means something and but but I know I
just I know the community and I know
it's a push back he's got before it even
happens
so like either Bungie under delivers and
the the hardcore community that wanted
trials in the first place is not
satisfied or they they deliver
accurately and then everyone else gets
met so they're kind of in a lose-lose
situation but obviously the right call
is to make the trial stuff as sick as
possible if I and make the meta as
balanced as you can and then you have to
eliminate cheating as much as you can or
else that's gonna
strive to load actually so I'm curious
what if they're gonna do some sort of
pay wall or some sort of light or levels
police gap or something to to lead more
people out but I'm just nervous that's
something or multiple things is gonna go
wrong we're gonna have all these debates
and I mean I guess the positive thoughts
aside about like worrying about Bungie
delivering necessarily it's it's a
combination of what buddies can deliver
with how the community act to it and
yeah you can't control both of those say
that absolutely absolutely absolutely
you make a valid point again all be
everything that he you know a puppy or a
I see any uh he definitely I was like I
mean this you had said before was like
one it needs to be behind the season
past is that ten dollars just gonna stop
cheating stop the free people especially
on Steam on PC that was one the
aesthetic you would be like happy with
Egyptian but I'll be curious what they
do is the aesthetic but your biggest one
was the rewards and I think that yes
where whether it be the armor of the
weapons like your doctrine of passings
you know those things need to me hmm
coming back and those needs need to be
sought after whether it is a struggle to
get them for 80% of the population just
like I play this for PvE why is all the
stuff in PvP go play that other part of
the game cuz this guess what that's what
this we had a season of gambit thank you
we can add a season of Percival that's
why but but in in Cassie's defense this
is where Tosh is gonna be right in the
sense that as much as I love trials and
I'm the pvp guy there will be chirping
if there's no PvE if it can't be season
of the Drifters basically what I'm
saying it can't be a situation where
trials is back and then that's the end
game you know that's the loop of the
season like there has to be a new PvE
activity to keep that base you know
engage you don't say so I do have this
tight line where they have to walk well
it has to be enough for PvE guys to
still be able to do something I just
don't want them to do a season 2 drifter
thing where it's like okay which was a
huge mistake which is like okay we're
gonna give you this new activity with
gambit but when we're gonna force you
into this other thing wrestling it and
create this stupid cyclical loop
you need to get the armor from reckoning
trials card every week by running oh my
god Bungie yep you better not do that
foolishness no learn full season of The
Drifter we cannot have that but could
tell you guys that I agree I think I
think they will have some sort of PvE
thing I just think it'll be it'll be
smaller yeah I don't know if it'll be as
big as sundial personally like I can't
tell cuz like this was kind of a down
season that it was smaller than shadow
keep on dying hybrids so maybe it'll be
bigger overall but just so much work has
to go into at least the trials gear if
well you know the moat I'm assuming
we're gonna get a couple Maps for it too
yes so that's gonna be a big chunk of
the season so whatever content we do get
is probably gonna be on the shorter side
I'm sure it's just somewhere between
like the undying backs offensive and
sundial like somewhere in between there
and like sundials not exactly the most
elaborate activity but it's you know
it's got three rows it's got bosses but
my guess would be some sort of low-key
PD thing and the trials is the main
focus every weekend so I gotta ask
Tennessee a Senate ridiculous question
real quick um so we're all attached just
for the record we're on Team
egyptian-themed armored correct oh yeah
they're not gonna do nine armored again
so I'd mom made that that's what I would
number was cool I like to see that
aesthetic somewhere else but it in the
bushes it's very clear that they're
gonna dude egyptian-themed yeah so it
seems like with all the banners hanging
in the tower so yes I may even say oh
and that's my dad so because we talked
about this what are you wait I want you
to give me the fate of these three NPCs
right osiris safe fourteen and brother
Vance as far as their role with trials
and this season break it down let's go
brother man season do anything he's
gonna stay
they've neutered that character so much
he's never gonna do that so he's just
gonna be a planetary vendor that's is
Osiris is back Zane is gonna do the
trials announcer I've been saying that
all along I think you'll he'll be a
vendor I don't I think you'll be the
trials vendor and he'll probably be in
whatever we're building nan mercury so
we'll probably have to go see him maybe
at mercury is my guess or maybe he stays
in the tower just runs it from afar if
he's not the trials vendor then I guess
Osiris could be the trials vendor
because there was some line about Osiris
saying it's like time to return to the
tower or something in the end of the
mission so maybe even if Saint is the
announcer and kind of running it then
Osiris could be the vendor for his own
event
in theory mmmm all I want before the
season ends is a freaking cutscene with
Saint and Osiris so that's my guess I
think they'll all be involved to some
extent but I am a hundred percent sure
Saints gonna be the trials announcer
like I have no question about that
I know actually I don't think they're
gonna compute visit brother bands at
this point personally but Wow
sure the press guys you said brother
Vance has been friends old hard and this
lizard I wish it I think everything you
said it's pretty much on my feeling is
yeah they're setting us up for Saint to
be I mean the announcer wewe would you
do the same mission to free him he's
talking to you in almost like crucible
speaker right guardian then turn it up
then when you do the Devils ruin quest
the banter between him and Shaq's you
know I'm saying like the way he would
run you know you're just giving away you
know these these left huh you know
amazing banter that's actually the stuff
that I loved about this easily with the
narrative moments it's probably the best
it's been in my opinion I know it's just
audio but I love that little stuff I
know byph is going crazy you know with
Lord it is mine just to get much to
process yeah oh so much the process you
know me so I think that's the case
I think sadly you may be right it's just
just maybe stuck there and won't have
any role which would be another Sloane
or after me is chillin there doing their
thing they don't move they don't get
updates they're just useless yeah break
dialog or something someday I yeah
there's something that I you know Cyrus
yeah yeah I was just a finish fit dude
is he no I was gonna say I never said it
I kept thinking about it's like I
actually think like some of these
activities when you guys said like I
wouldn't mind seeing it as a strike like
the Sun Dial when we get done the end
that could easily you can run that thing
as a sundial literally leave the
mechanics the same it just go stick it
in the strike play list if that thing
London I wonder if they might be
considering that honestly it is so much
content to just dip sort of like yeah
like okay like the VEX offensive bless
so that was very very simplest of
mechanics very simplistic but this
really seems like it could just be a
strike essentially just reorganize it a
little bit it just it would be such a
waste to just you get rid of it you
could even have everything here comes
back which they keep saying is gonna
happen I don't know when that will
happen to just like spend so much work
on a piece of content that's gone after
three months or a boss fight that's gone
after one month like they can't feel
good for the designers themselves much
less the playerbase I've never really
understood that no that one always seems
weird but yeah as like as you say it
would be so nice just to see that thing
hang around and you could even have a
different boss every time did it be like
a cool strike just because you'd get
random and maybe it's gonna be you know
Tom yeah hmm be like your freak accident
every so often be like the flare cloaks
is strike based opportunity yes rest in
peace but I really hope they take what
they've done with the obelisks and learn
or any of the planetary vendors for
shacks for Zavala to have them as a
system to level up have perks that you
get throughout the season like use them
and that way and give them as an
incentive to hey if you go run your
strike playlist you're starting to level
up and get this you know level him up
and now when you go words there's other
perks that you get to like they can use
that system very easily for many of
these other vendors a fry their seasonal
or longer-term mm-hmm I mean I still I'm
in faction rallies I don't know if those
are ever come
yeah would be a theory they'll invite
you a season a faction stuff like down
the road if we're just going with
endless seasons mm-hmm
that that seems to me like that could be
it good like you like you have a season
long community event where everyone
picks a faction that everyone competes
against this thing and that thing in the
Senate II I think that could be a good
concept for just a season in general is
there gonna be like a permanent
recurring thing like they used to be but
I think it'll be a good good seasonal
content I agree I could also envision it
almost like an imperial crown foundation
mark on a season so it's like you know
faction rally at this event that lasts
you know a couple of weeks or whatever
whatever or they can go grandiose like
you said and make it a seize a whole
seasonal activity kind of thing and you
know say there's turmoil in a towel or
whatever you know say whatever they come
up with well yeah now that you say that
like it's pretty clear that you could do
something a lot like the period
foundation where it's you have you know
the different things the progress bars
but like unlike imperial foundation
where we all know we're gonna hit the
end we've literally made it a
competition and like in the tower you
can see like oh X person yes tokens and
yes it's a different and there's
different rewards based on that like you
would actually feel like you were doing
something like they did that a little
bit in the past with like whoever won
got the Primo weapon karate or whatever
but I feel like they could expand on
that concept for like a community
challenge among among the seasons I
agree I think I think this is the new
again when it comes to this new content
format they got to get creative and I
think you know obviously again we did
this know hi moon
there's no vicarious vicious you know
I'm saying we have to be cognizant of
that so I think this is the like I told
you yeah I think this is the new hustle
so to speak as far as these community
visit low and long as they do I'm right
in there and they're fun you know I
think they can get away with that
between spacing certain content you know
and allow them to do the other stuff so
yeah again potential is there you know I
think the this is war I think kind of an
experimental phase with them as far as
like you know the whole thing when we
went through the hours of time you know
that kind of stuff you know all this
stuff I feel as if I'm playing around
with different different ideas and
community building kind of things as
opposed to this hard and
FASS you know recon that stuff that they
got to really put all these resources
and and stuff in that they just don't
have at a time yeah I mean it'd be a
nice way to for balancing out it's not
something you need desperately hardcore
but also I mean do you remember the
faction class items that were exotic oh
yeah stuff like that was a way you could
put that at the end of I mean gives of
all of something like that for him his
little weenie but to have something to
do but like but if I'm gonna go run a
strike playlist if I'm actually doing
that as a reason to not maybe not get
much out of those because the rewards
aren't that great in the strike placed
itself but I'm leveling him up and maybe
there's an in-game maybe for a full year
there's an exotic class item or
something like that you can earn from
him that's like universal in some way
you could do that yeah giving some of
those guys life just as you said like
the seasons I would love to see us these
infections that would be awesome
oh he's in a season of turmoil or
something like that like a turmoil in
the tower that sounds like a really bad
book title you should write turmoil in
the tower option the options are there
man yes today we'll see what happens
yeah oh there's not too much else after
we get done with after we get done with
iron banner we are really pretty much
wrapping the season up huh there's no
hurry costs whenever we finish it
whatever worthy lady fighting the beacon
mmm-hmm and it'd be everybody's got
everything done for their title you guys
got everything lined up suede on the
imperium foundation finishing up just
then yeah just the foundation and then I
gotta go run some basic strikes I think
I'm done after that yeah me too I got
you got to do the points thing with the
solar yeah let you go to the yeah me too
how about the sake well I got every time
moto change that next season yeah they
did a little better they'll a cut off
the last step for it so I made it a
little shorter but it was just it was
like give me I don't want like hey
here's a like they cut it off but I was
like can we get a little creative
sometimes on these quests they're just
like I know they're checkboxes they hit
to keep you in a playlist but something
different I don't think they need those
like individual mini quests like if they
have ritual weapons that essentially is
that so I don't know where they're both
it's just I agree pointless I would make
the ritual request a little more
involved than they've been you could do
the vanguard sidearm one and last right
I'm so easy yeah that's like make that a
little harder and then guys combine them
and then you don't need two different
sets a quest yeah it's like I'm late
enough gambit going for my shotgun I'm
kind of good especially that's like wait
I played it for Python at the very
beginning I end up like gamete pumped
two and a half months like I did that
like week one
I never there's no reason to play so in
one of my boredom phases I farmed a full
Reaper set for each of my classes just
in case I have to do gambit again in the
future
I used it yet but I have it now you got
it
yeah very lean yeah mmm same deal man
same deal
well I was like I mean for some how we
always I feel like we have a lot to talk
about it goes fast but as we are looking
down like III is changing ye consul
reveals are coming and we also have like
quite a few games being announced one of
which happened yesterday which I didn't
know about until the day before um
there's a lot of competition for this
game that is still trying to like
scratch at destiny just chilling out at
the top of the hill Destiny killers own
debt mm-hmm
lining up to take their shot every
single one of them I was just kind of
curious because anthem is working on
doing they've said no who knows how long
it's gonna take a completely full like
rebuild I mean the the flying mechanics
were there but they had the bones of a
game they didn't have a game right
Division two had a start people enjoyed
and kind of fell off pretty hard and now
we're going back to New York
we've got outriders which is gonna be
next gen crossover if you want to call
it that's probably a better term as you
said Paul but got a crossover generation
so this is leading into the next one and
that's from Square Enix that's a gears
division anthem mix whatever so I just
wanted to get you guys thoughts of from
other stuff that you've seen of these
other games versus obviously what dusty
is doing do you see anything that's like
hey I wish that was doing this or what
are the things have you guys seemed that
you would like to see these other games
do because those are all ones we've all
tried it's been a decent amount of time
on
they just haven't held our attention
like that's these those curious what
you'd like to see each of those do just
get what a seed man I mean obviously the
competition is rising like he was saying
it yet outriders which you know we
talked about briefly you know breathe
pre pre-show and then obviously I have
them an individual let's start what out
right is first like where are you at
with what you seen so far and um you
know basic mechanics of the game and
stuff like that yeah my initial presence
about riders were not the best like I
didn't go to the hands-on event so I'm
just basing it off all the videos and
stuff not suffer fret about it and it
just it looked like the division with
superpowers which in theory could be
interesting but it all looked a little
bit generic and then it wasn't really
until I saw a gameplay later where I
realized it's you don't really have to
be in cover that much from what I was
seeing where you can be more out in the
open and kind of running around and
using your powers and like not just kind
of poking and cover shooting like
lightning vision or gears then
sounded a little more interesting to me
and a lot of the powers I saw like the
guy who stops time
yeah the cool that looked really good in
practice and then you know people I know
they're saying that the gunplay feels
really good um so all of that kind of
combines to me like okay like I'm you
know I'll check this out I'm interested
in this even though I didn't have any
bearing like a week ago yeah I think
it's gonna have trouble kind of standing
out and its aesthetic is just very
destiny like even if gunplay is more
division or anthem it like they use the
lead image today where it's like it's
literally like warlock title I guess was
a fourth hidden class or whatever but
yeah it's just it's very se me and then
from what I've heard about the storyline
like it's a pretty hard our kind of
rating we're you know dropping f-bombs
and like this guy who pleaded a quest
and he drops off the suits head they're
like an npc yes yes I watch that yes
maybe that that's something we don't
really see in this genre is people going
in at hard so maybe that could be
interesting but the story does sound
kind of generic and like it's 85% of the
anthem story but yeah what's being
described to me but it does look
interesting enough between the lute and
the skill trees and the different
abilities where I'm like okay if this
combines the best parts of like anthem
and Diablo and the division that sounds
that's all stuff I'd like so that sounds
like something I could be interested in
but mm-hmm
no I'm not gonna like preach that it's a
destiny killer destiny killer
let's go e you're up next maybe out
Ronnie's gonna do outright his first so
let's do what you see which is just
watching yesterday it was I mean you
said it kind of similar it's like I feel
like I've ridden this horse before I
feel like I've been known as Madden
because I mean I played now I'm not as
invested in the gears franchise but when
I got into the whole cover thing it
reminded me I was like the whole cover
pop up and pop out is kind of like and
when you said you don't have to as much
that was actually intriguing because I
was like if it's a cover shooter I'm
gonna get I do get a little tired of
those you to a point because you're just
like run to this cover oh no they're
near me
let me run over here to this cover oh no
they and you're like always training
with that so I know that's pretty cheesy
description but there
or to it the abilities seemed pretty
cool like the timepiece and then you've
got the Pyromancer I think was the
trickster the Pyromancer in the
Devastator I mean where the green mmm
trying to remember from one days of
information so forgive me if I'm wrong
uh the skill trees seemed a little more
in depth which I do kind of like the
idea there of again something word
destiny skill trees are pretty pretty
pretty lean yeah one two and three and
you get like you get this then you're
good to go so like again I do like the
idea of the fact that it's a little more
single-player so there's no PvE that
they've got a balance to it yeah but it
is also sanding a little more
Borderlands of if you like finish your
run of the game there might be multi
r--'s to go through Borderlands didn't
hooked me that long because I guess like
I didn't even I made it barely through
like the first run mmm personally I was
like this I didn't get to like the
Mayhem's and stuff like that for because
it was like there's always seeming
something else for me to do I was like I
don't want to go run the same stuff over
and I'm saying that as I play destiny so
that's kind of stupid but it's fair but
I do again it's like what kind of floats
your boat and like the menu system
looked very very very dusty hard cuz you
got like three sets of armor two weapons
a sidearm you're like rarities of gear
so it's like it has potential of like
all the things but it's like ooh as you
said Paul is like what is gonna make it
stand out as something that tells me hey
I really want to play this now is it
like the cussing and like the harder
edge to it that's gonna make me feel
like ass it's kind of a fun game we'll
shot the arm type thing or is it just
like it's another RPG shooter type and
it just doesn't quite hold me and I
don't know but that's yeah kind of
worried yes that's a good assessment
I'll jump in um you know I was wait with
Tassie initially when I first saw the
aesthetic I was like hey this lid magic
merit okay like I don't know it just
it's something about it didn't grab me
at first and whatever I saw just did
motivate me but again I want to shout
out my man talking Duncan from IGN he
had a great I believe 15 minute or
whatever it was of gameplay and watching
him play the game got me excited because
again the cover stuff I agree with you
II like after a while you know and I'm a
gears guy but you know it does get a
little boring
you know the cover-to-cover kind of
thing but when I saw him utilizing the
time stopping power and just running
almost all around the map like a madman
a little bit excited me cause it's like
I didn't want to feel restricted to
cover except in this game felt optional
which I don't mind you know I'm saying
which is I mean you still use it but you
it's more power and ability based and I
was like okay I kind of like that and
I'm a big fan of like cool boss
mechanics and boss encounters and this
look like it had that you know over a
couple of bosses just really quit
fighting this guy with lightning from a
distance and he's moving around shifting
and stuff like that it looks like you
had three abilities at one time the only
the cool thing that's the narrative is
seem like it's very narrative and story
based you know I'm saying kind of thing
you know with the four players that's
cool you know I was disappointed that
when I think thunking mention is that
then what times where NPCs would give
you dialogue choices and the developer
openly says it doesn't matter so I'm
just like well why is it gonna damn game
that cop would have a choice exactly I
swear one of them s like why is why is
there cover it's like you really need to
be a cover no that's like the why is
that system in there it's like in the
game I feel of a it's just one of those
things where just like I get I I come
from that whole Bioware school where
it's like you know that if you're gonna
put something in the game I want some
cause and effect some change that's
gonna you know happen and affect the
game world so it was just literally you
know whatever and then you know I do
like the visceral nature of it I will
say this I I went from something I had
no interest in interested in to say okay
this looks decent
I might rock out with it but I can't see
it even if I ain't I don't know if I can
see it taking me away from destiny for
any extended period of time I need to
see more that would blow me away at this
current stage it's better than I
expected but again not that's just where
I'm at right now without writers I want
to give it a chance to see we see we
know more information that comes out and
so on and so forth but I want to doubt
pivot to the other two you know games
obviously that that's been going on and
me II you got to talk about our good old
Iron Man simulate a minute
let's start with that first um it's been
it's been a hard road let's just say
it's been a hard road you know for a
good friends if Bioware and um you know
we all know the story I have to get into
it at nauseam you know but we did hear
you know recent news that they are not
abandoning this franchise that they're
in a sense doing a reboot so I don't
read they're pulling a Leo on the
Titanic they're gonna write them yeah so
what Britain is a sea like buying
metaphor to you like you know with what
you've heard what you see I mean we're
not seen anything but what you've heard
do you think anthem could have like that
that that no man's sky that that taken
King rise from ashes kid it can it
happen do you think daddy way yeah my my
gut tells me no and I know we've seen
this happen before with different games
were like okay the taken King revitalize
destiny Reaper of souls revitalize
Diablo no man's sky
you know busted their ass and and turned
the whole game around I think there's a
lot of different things happening in
this situation however where a game like
destiny like they had so much invested
into it and it was their only thing they
were working on where they like couldn't
let it fail essentially where and same
with no man's sky like hella games was
working on that and that alone Bioware
is a big company and yet it is working
on to more important projects which are
the new Dragon Age and then a new Mass
Effect which is further away and then I
don't know if EA is is gonna make them
do Star Wars stuff eventually too and go
back to the roots there and so that's
like three potential things that should
in theory have priority over an anthem
reboot so I'm wondering just how much
they are truly devoting all this and
given that anthem debuted like anthem
wasn't like so anthem isn't Mass Effect
like people don't have a history with
anthem other than the last you know 11
months of the game it has some some
people that are like hardcore anthem
bands but it's a very small numbers so
something they would have
you it is something that brings in
either people who didn't get it the
first time or people that kind of
laughed it out of existence when it
launched it was bad and like it did get
a lot better in time and like by the
ends you know they they have fixed a lot
of it core issues with it but I don't
know what what they're gonna bring to
the table that's gonna create this kind
of situation where if they're reusing
the same map and stuff like that like
are they building an entirely new
campaign like are they essentially
rebuilding the game from scratch like
it's hard for me to imagine that they
would be doing that so right it's I'm
just trying to think of like a potential
situation in which this works and while
I'm not gonna say it's possible it just
seems a lot more improbable than like
your final fantasy you're you're no
man's sky like based on a bunch of
different reasons you guys are gonna
love aisle pita so now I hate to plug my
own show but you guys gotta love I hope
you they said but I want to bring it
back in a sense that I hear what you
said and and you are completely right
there's nothing you're saying is
inaccurate I guess you know from what we
heard from the stories of the
development cycle and everything that
was going on behind the scenes and you
know the Frostbite engine and then the
leadership thing and Casey leaves and
then these guys leave and then really
none of the old-school
Bioware guys were really there basically
for my understanding like the game was
developing like you know like 12 months
and flying was added at the last minute
and stuff like that so what what about
the the thought process that because
again the word on the street is that
there was no single unified direction
for the game right they would go into
meetings and they would discuss you know
what they want anthem to be and there
would be no resolution because form I
understand there was no leadership right
saying okay this is division for anthem
this is what we're gonna do the thing
kept changing and changing going through
this dis metamorphosis so if let's just
say they had Casey or whoever it is is
now in charge as the single leader lead
for anthem and the leadership up top
changes um do you think that they could
possibly like nail down a specific
gameplay loop and say okay this is what
it is this is what anthem is we don't
have to go to Tarsus every five minutes
and you know like
can we like is there any hope in that
just the gameplay loop itself like can
that you think be possibly resolved as
the answer is yes
because by the end the gameplay loop was
actually getting pretty good there just
wasn't with the Cataclysm and then some
of the stuff they're doing like it was
getting a lot better but to your point
like if you're like okay well what if
Casey's in charge of things that like
shouldn't is he
like shouldn't shouldn't they be
announcing something like that it'd be a
lot more reassuring if it was like if he
came out in that blog post he was like
I'm running the anthem reboot now I have
no idea morning acts anthem not the only
person I know for sure even not so on
anthem is like one of the community
managers like I literally have no idea
what Bioware is is working on this
relieving it or anything and like the
guys I do know
are working on Dragon Age Mass Effect so
I just I don't understand like who is
behind this reboot and how many
resources are being devoted to it and
like it took like all of Bungie or all
of hello games all again the Final
Fantasy team to like go back and do
these things from scratch so if this is
what like 25-30 percent of Bioware at
best working on this like I'm just
wondering what the end result is gonna
be
and like I hope it works it's just good
point very it's very weird kind of on
its it's more unprecedented situation
than people think
yeah because those other games were so
different in their respective context no
you're right I'm gonna give it to Eamon
I mean you know it's like he's going but
I am a simulator me what was was going
on it was like I mean the whole honestly
I still in my mind I picture my
interceptor and I loved how that guy
felt whoo it was so much fun fast fluid
jumping around swiping like mm-hmm
the function of what they had for the
for forget what they would be called now
damn could be Tassie doing his proper
work staying up on all lingo so he's at
the javelins in and of themselves were
cool but when you take something like no
man's sky they vastly under delivered
they spent time and they gave what kind
of
what they had fully promised after time
I feel like anthem tried to deliver a
campaign they had levels they had quote
strikes and then they're in game with
like the cat the Cataclysm and stuff I'm
like I don't know how you as unless as
Tess he said like do you do a completely
separate campaign is it like a free
sequel like I don't know he deploy
everything that happened I don't know
how you move it forward because some
people unless they're gonna like Final
Fantasy did it right they're like we're
shutting it down we're breaking the
entire universe and then you're reborn
like that was the name was reborn
because you were born again and they
started over and I was like okay that
makes sense they need to almost pull one
of those at this point right or at least
thematically for things to make sense
and shut it down and have a new campaign
and all of that stuff hopefully their
campaign is a little different than
outriders because those are control a
little flows for me well the other
problem is I think I think whatever they
do has to be free to have your old
singing gaming disagree their souls and
and taking King we're both paid
expansions and like no one is gonna be
like okay there's an ant say there is a
big anthem expansion like no one's gonna
pay $40 for more anthem content outside
of like us like the ultimate hardcore no
you can do it like people would laugh
that out and so it does have to be free
how much how much work are you really
gonna devote to that and especially when
you can buy anthem by itself now for
like five bucks or whatever you know and
so this is why I'm amazed Bioware's even
doing this in the first place I know I I
just this decision-making process like
I'm not some you know business executive
so I I don't know behind the scenes but
me it just seems like they should have
learned some important lessons about
gameplay and loot and stuff and then
just like throwing all that into Mass
Effect go back to the series people want
to play and like be like well if we
tried it didn't work out right
that's it so like I I'm just amazed that
this is the path they went down and
while I hope it pans out I'm just I I
can't believe this is the call a made
this it's a good point guys we let you
finish
it's just I mean so AB deal and Chatta
saying isn't calling no man skies and
fair it's like one is looter one is a
pure sandbox that's the part it's like
they're not they're not but asla is more
of like one is a giant sandbox through
explore planets and stuff like that and
the others is definitely it's a looter
fighter shoot or whatever you want to
call it but it still got a point to
where you of those of us who played it I
mean you played 50 hours you played
through the campaign you leveled up your
character you did the strikes you kind
of did the higher tiers and like we
played what encompassed most of a game
it's just it died right so to do it I
mean the only way you can charge for it
is to literally I mean that's why I was
like I don't know how you do it for free
or business Lee I don't biz business Lee
there's no use in business Lee I like
that that's move right here the first
time set it
oh good brother
from a business sense I don't know how
the free thing makes sense for the cost
that's gonna take to make something that
is substantial enough to bring people
back but if you put that much time into
it do you call it like anthem - I mean I
need you to Reaper of souls or do you
call it an expansion in charge say 2530
for a smaller expansion I don't know how
it falls but to do it for free I'm with
you Paul I don't know how that makes
sense but again I don't know who's gonna
pay for something but they gonna charge
so they get something for it so they're
gonna loose loose I don't understand how
it works I think I got a hustle for them
that they can do and we it's actually a
transition it's a hustle up there yeah I
got I got a husband but I'm working on
some hospital-like
and he's actually gonna transition into
the next game and want us to talk about
what your division but I think we all
listen the game is desert go now let's
not even talk about you know the play
accounts there you know the
interactivity with the game we get it
exactly now here's your thing we know
even if they redo this game revamp it
fix the gameplay loop you know they
cannot come out the gate and say hey for
a smooth $40 is it new expansion you
know you know say like you can't you you
have to earn the goodwill of the people
who you burned who invested into this
game right so you have to do something
kind of like kind of like what the
visitors doing which is kind of like you
you give to get gaming away for free
pretty much right you give a free update
let's just say well a lot of just the
gameplay loop changes right so you give
the community to feel and say okay this
is you know Armour 2.0 this is Luke 2.0
this is how it's working everybody
starts getting to feel okay alright we
like this gameplay loop and then maybe
you stack it or you know with a stagger
it with like maybe a week to two weeks
of an expansion right afterwards after
people get it they say hey this is we
like what's going on here we like this
direction then you come out with your
Cataclysm right or whatever that content
that you were supposed to deliver on the
roadmap and I think that's the only way
you could possibly sell it I mean I
would love for all that to be
all-inclusive for free I don't know how
that works from a business perspective
but I got
that's the Buchert sir like you know I
don't know how that works but you gotta
you you have to earn back the trust of
your community you you have to show them
that you are committed to this game and
I think maybe that's one way I want to
shout out slow he says this how you
doing completely revamp the base game
and improve the experience make the
campaign better fix the gameplay look
kinda what I said they're not nor do you
say the same things well being you're
the same point you said they're not long
after that have an expansion at its peak
that's literally because I think that is
the smart play what the vision is trying
to do right now we know division is
where it's at you know and and we'll get
into that why but I think what's cool is
like that yo $3 right now everybody who
want it $3 get in get down lay down
we got $3 you know you want it free is
basically 399 right so you get everybody
back in the base right you give a little
small little patch update say hey this
whatever whatever then you already know
warlords is coming and blah blah blah
and I think that's the way I kind of
like when division does I just hate that
they have to wait this long to get the
player base so upset before they decide
to do these things but I think that
maybe the shot anthem god but I'm
bringing back to you testing like do you
think that could be viable for anthem as
far as that kind of a strategy or I
think it's not viable than any other
option I've heard and like I believe in
in rewarding a dev for working hard and
if they're gonna spend six eight months
reworking it and doing all this work
like I think that's probably worth $40
it's just a matter of convincing people
that already spent $60 that they deserve
40 more dollars so I it kind of raised
me of Diablo 3 so like they introduced
Lou 2.0 and like adventure mode and
rifts and I think you could do I think
you could do a lot of that without
necessarily buying Reaper souls and so
you could you could like experiment with
it and then if you wanted it to do like
the full new campaign content then you
would buy that so that seems the most
viable to me and like I know anthem
would get laughs out of the door if they
gave you something that cost money but
it
that's the only reason any of this makes
sense because what otherwise what the
game cost nothing the microtransaction
store is like one of the most
optional I've ever seen in a game like
this like yeah and then if the if the
new rework expansion is totally free
like with its why why would they be
doing this at all if at the end of the
road they didn't think they could charge
for stuff like no man no man sky did it
where at least for a while they were
just it was all free and they were
charging people they just wanted people
to pick up the base game which was still
like it still caused something so that
was the plan for them but also they were
owned by EA and didn't have quite as
high of no profit expectations to so it
another part of me wonders how much of
this is just reputation building and yes
just so Bioware could say we did it like
yes you know we don't want to screw ups
in a row between Andromeda and anthem so
like even if it costs us like people
will respect us for putting in the hard
work and like fixing the game and that
they can show up or not but like we did
it like you know we are making amends
and and we're still making good things
and then if the next Dragon Age is good
the next Mass Effect's good then they're
back to being Bioware that we respect
and are like a treasured studio which I
don't think you know they're quite in
the same spot is they used to be so part
of me wonders if that's a pretty
significant factor here and what Bioware
might be willing to sacrifice just base
just to get some of that goodwill back
right no I agree I mean yeah I'll let
you finish up with what anthem in an
auto and play with the division but you
agree um which as you say well yeah you
know I mean it's like both of what you
guys are saying even if it was as you're
saying take all that stuff like the loot
2.0 the adventurers like whatever
they're gonna do for anthem take that
stuff bring it in whether it's a public
test realm situation to try some new
stuff and like have people who are
active in the game be like hey invite
anybody who's still like an active
player hey this is what we're working on
for anthem 2.0 whatever you want to call
it this is we want you guys to kind of
help test it help work with your
community be a little more open with
what's going on and kind of be bored
facing but also yeah give those tests of
hey this is a like take the system
they're gonna put in or compared to that
in the game so people can try it so no I
totally agree with a way to do that but
I don't think I don't think whatever
they do can be for free but I do think
it could be the PR move of the word
trying to be like Anubis off no we're
not gonna let our games die we're gonna
take our siege for three
years and turn it into something bright
they're gonna try and stick with their
games a little later or at least prove
as you said for the PR face to say hey
our games don't totally suck see how
long we warned on this one even if it
doesn't start doing working to make sure
it's good like right stick with us we're
working the long haul type thing which
is trying to go with that but let me not
make sense actually
yeah I'm witchy I think I think that's
literally what it is I mean I think it's
its reputation it's it's community trust
and I think it's one of those things
where they look at the franchise as a
whole and say look there's still a
foundation here that is worth salvaging
for maybe a future sequel right so let's
not completely abandon let's let's let's
put some work in on this base to get to
get the gameplay loop or whatever it is
to where the community actually likes it
kind of and almost like you ending off
like division one right you you started
off kinda you know and then you bring it
back up they start to add adding modes
and stuff like that and you get it to a
point of respectability and then next
generation consoles PlayStation 5 X
about Series X it's like boom maybe you
know in the middle of the cycle anthem 2
now with all the things you learn right
and now the graphical fidelity so the
damn consoles can actually handle it was
my brother's kids they were playing on
their normal P as far and I bowled
either show or blue that's on my xbox 1
X X damn yeah I didn't even know that
was possible
yeah Wow yeah and listen I had it on
both and Adam was rough on console
I almost thought it was way too
ambitious for console thankfully I was
with you or you know PC master-race
Network it was always nice always nice
that 60 frame was beautiful while you
take off into the sky oh it was basic so
hopefully now with the next-generation
CPUs you know Rises and everything those
SSDs you know it would really be a nice
showcase hold this down one transition
to the last one glass game which was um
obviously division and we know what's
going on now you know as we hinted you
know they definitely came out with a
title update a new episode and then they
trap the trailer for warlords of New
York so more content you know a lot of
background rebuilding on gear set stuff
a lot of things the community you know
we're clamoring for you know a shout to
my boy Italian he's curling in a what is
it the division to take indicator you
know a lot of people are excited you
know shot oh boy slow-mo he's in the
chat right now he's a hardcore division
guy and um you know I wanted to bring it
to you guys you know I can't fight it
you see like where where you think this
thing can go you know have you even
tried to throw it on I know
Tasi feel very strongly about division
I've seen your York avid Terry about you
know kind of leaving the game and no
incentive to really come back so any of
this stuff excites you where you at
right now wallow to New York and the new
division content announced yeah so just
it was very unexpected I didn't think
they would have an expansion of this
size today oh they connect sorry you met
you wait yeah I cut offices which are
back yeah I I didn't know they would
have an expansion of this size that was
frankly very surprising to me I just
didn't think they were going to go down
that road after the seasonal models they
they had before I will say this so this
is definitely enough to get me back
playing I will I will pick it up on day
one I will play the expansion I would be
surprised if I like stick around to do a
ton of endgame grinding after that like
I'm curious to see how it works with the
new stat system and stuff but all
throughout the division 2 I've had a
problem kind of sticking with the end
game and maybe some of that initially
was like this stuff they kept
introducing for the endgame like the
raid like just didn't that didn't seem
like it was for me at all like it was
waiting on a console at first and then I
kind of gave up and I always liked the
division in terms of the divisions
campaigns are really good so I am very
excited for the story missions and like
the air and keener storyline and
everything like that and going back to
New York and like I used to live in
lower Manhattan so I want to see if I
can like see my place select some like
that so I I'm very excited just to get
in and do that mm-hmm I just
fundamentally I I like playing almost
every other loot shooter on the market
more like interviews when laying I like
I see more I like
more talents more I like playing anthem
or I just think and then is more ominous
then the cover based division stuff and
I think for a third-person cover shooter
it's very good and it's gotten better in
time even but if I'm splitting time
between all these different games and I
have to start choosing and then if
there's new options that come out and in
the fall like it is tough to see myself
sticking with division longer term like
it's it's enough where I will spend 40
bucks on this expansion and play it
repeat it and you know play for an extra
20 30 hours and then game but it's at
this point it's hard for me to see the
division ever rivaling destiny in terms
of my overall interest or another game
like that so it's fine but I I don't
know if this is gonna be some like you
know huge gene seen the light moment for
the division I think it's just gonna be
more solid content that I'll be okay
then I'll probably move on again then
let me clear it before I pass these East
cheese he's having too much fun with all
this comedy so you'd love it everything
you say it but they with this little
internal battle this is what but my
question though is okay so what would
division have to do Oh is there anything
they could do to say you know what
dis dis now I like this direction like
is there any fundamental changes that
you think is holding it back or it's
just as simple as hey I don't like this
cover thing you know looter shooter
style I'm just not into this realistic
kind of a you know boots on the ground
style thing when it's not as fun as
being a mech or it's not as fun as
having space magic how to see it's
probably that and like I feeling I feel
a little bad because I feel like the
division for what it is is doing
everything right for the most part and
at least from what we've heard now is
moving in the right direction and I
think these are all improvements
it's just will it ever you know but
become a game that I want
to play at that level and like I played
I played the Division one at that level
kind of right but that was back when
destiny wasn't as good as it is now
right there were no other shooters
essentially so he was like between that
and like playing years old Diablo 3 and
then like struggling through whatever
destiny was doing at the time so I put a
lot more time into it now when I have so
many more options and everything is kind
of at an elevated level I guess I have
to start making the harder choices and
it's not really even the divisions fault
it just at a certain point I have to
realize that this is a series that like
I like for certain aspects namely the
campaign and like the environment sign
and stuff like that and then I no matter
what they do I'm probably just not gonna
prefer its cover model to these three
other shooters that I find more
enjoyable to play if not that's fair
that's fair I can't respect that let's
get um oh boy he and he's been laying
these shop and his job is so good
so even warlords do you're not enticed
so I will try it
but for me I'm in a similar boat as all
for part of me when I'm playing games
whether it be Diablo or destiny or I
mean so many different ones that I'll
play it's like I'm trying to trying to
get away not go put myself in the middle
of New York with a gun like having
altruism
so it's the point of like I mean I do
enjoy the space magic aspect like anthem
when these like crazy biomech suits and
then even the idea it's like I haven't
seen out writers I'm putting I'm gonna
call that something wrong at some you
know I am that title is consider me
something about like even as that is
like even if it's a cover shooter but
it's like it's faster and there's
abilities to it it already seems a
little more intriguing to me just
because it takes if it has good gunplay
like that's kind of a good thing destiny
has amazing gunplay my vision has decent
gunplay I'm not gonna argue but it's I
mean Destiny's just on a level of its
own oh yes another low but if it has no
listen gunplay with abilities and skill
tree and RPG to where I'm not just
shooting another human in the Flake I'm
putting a snuff 50 caliber sniper in a
dude's head and he's just fine breaks
that breaks immersion for you I mean
it's a game I understand like yes it has
a huge health bar so I'm trying to
whittle it down that's fine but if I'm
shooting like a monster or some crazy
floating electric demon and he's got a
little bit more work to put into him in
my head that makes a little bit more
sense of course I guess now I know like
division two and have put in like the
armor mechanics and like chipping on the
pieces and then they died really quickly
when you did that was a great way to
combat that psychology for me that was
like I'm really tired at tired of
literally shooting who meets like that
was not fun so when they actually change
to the armor that was kind of cool but I
tried to and I kind of missed the window
when I went to go try it it was a little
late I tried it a bit with my brother
and ended up playing with a friend who
was literally like 30 and just like like
I was in true he was just plowing for
ahead of me so it wasn't that
it's just kind of hard when you go from
like nova bombs and things like that to
go to these little secret roans they
don't might have the same feel and
pizzazz to them that I want and also
when it comes to like your it's like the
the stats and stuff like that it does
still seem a little weird that like you
know I've got more skill point just it
always seemed a little I don't mind
stats to a point mm-hmm but it was
almost too much if I know we kill almost
too much minutia how much too much too
much and that's one of the things
they're doing almost wait wait hold I
got a push back at this is the same man
what I'm a 2.0 to be this in-depth
robust you know system but this matter I
don't need sixty thousand stats Oh can't
have all these big max adoptions is that
what we talk about as a listen we do it
he okay there are min maxing options
that's fine it was like it just didn't
feel like for and I never out anybody in
check you guys can freak the hell out if
you want to I played a fair amount of
Division one I was at dark zone I had my
fair amount of time in that one kind of
the same but like Division two I did not
play that much so if my lake I didn't
even play through the full campaign in
Division two so I am not in the best
place to talk about this I'm just saying
of my mentality towards the game awfully
I was like I went through it was like
trying to figure out okay hey I got this
magazine it's got one like 50% magazine
instead of 47 like I remember going for
those roles and that was like it was a
good way to get a little bit extra on
your weapons but after a while mm-hmm it
just got I ran out of gas for me for
whatever reason I can't put a paint on
it or put um you know it is hard to put
a pin on that's something I said I get
it I think you both nailed it I think I
think you know there's what aspect of
the cover aspect you know the kind of
more methodical kind of thing there's
the other aspect of the realism you know
and kind of breaking the immersion in
the MMO space and realism I mean you
know I get what you guys are going I um
every shelf a this is a fun one cuz oh I
think I think what it is for me I
thought when they came out the box right
I was like wow this is probably one of
the best launches to a looter shooter
I've seen and
sometime they felt refined they felt
like they learned all the lessons from
Division one you know and I was
thoroughly enjoying it I got to 30 no 30
I had a good time now where they lost me
and shout the smelled of he's in the
chest he's hardcore division stress
level is that when it came down to the
end game because I was surprised but
it's did they even seemed like they had
the end game lined up correctly they
were gonna say we're gonna do it right
here we're gonna do this we could have
all this content then the raid drops I
shouted my boy you know Marco style but
it drops and it's like you need this
very specific build to be able to even
deal with the first boss and I'm like
hmm now the thing that really aggravated
me was that they just felt to me that I
got the vibe that massive felt arrogant
like nope we're not changing this this
is how it's staying and you've got this
small percentage of console guys I
didn't even beat the raid this super
small percentage that on PC that that
just barely did it and I was just
surprised how doggin they were to not
listening to their community be upset so
I'm like alright let's see how long this
lasts and then it kept going and then I
kept hearing other things and you know
and it got to the point where I'm like
I'm seeing my hardcore
division content creators playing
destiny I'm waking up one day and Marko
styles like I'm doing destiny I'm like
yeah I'm like so at my mind I'm like
okay what happened to the division this
didn't this to me was one of the most
surprising falls from grace that I've
seen with a lunar shooter that had such
a dominant star in my opinion so now you
know people fall away from it okay
grateful for correct reasons you know
they start to come back finally now they
starting to put in these updates you
know that people are clamoring for so to
speak you know um as far as this you
know the new-look thing I love it I have
a soft spot you know I'm a New Yorker
that's just me don't swear man bro steel
so I love all this stuff from that
standpoint you know I want to see where
they go
I love the fact that I think what they
do that Ubisoft does is really good is
where they know the games did
they have this great way of getting you
back in as far as baking know the price
low and get your back in and stuff like
that and then setting up the content the
key is going to be you know how long it
keeps us engaged you know as far as the
end game there from my understanding
there's still no raid coming you know
I'm saying no other rate coming I just
want to make sure that they learn the
mistakes of their in-game problem you
know I'm saying because you cannot not
listen to your community especially when
the numbers are showing that people are
not engaging in that and the same thing
with you know the dark zones and so on
and so forth so I'm pulling for them I'm
gonna give it a shot you know I just I
just want to see what happens I want to
see if you know people really you know
get invested again and if it couldn't
you know may come at but wait where you
guys at with that part yeah I mean I
that was the exact moment Division two
lost me to was the raid where it's like
okay how do I put 100 150 hours into
this and like have taught to your stuff
and like then this is just this endgame
activity that I don't even have a prayer
for and it was it was it was the
difficulty but it was also it was the
first activity that didn't have
matchmaking yeah like there was like I
didn't even know where to start looking
for an eighth for that like what I guess
I mean I guess I could like hit up
Twitter or something with you know all
my followers but like besides that like
there's no there's no like division lfg
there's no app like no component acid
matching people so like it was gonna be
a huge pain to even get people together
for it and then if it was like
impossible to complete and like no
console players even beat it in like the
first 72 hours or something because it
was just that I'm like I don't wanna
spend 21 hours at this and so like
eventually no they made they made
changes so I'm like they made some
easier and then you could love a lot
more and do it but looking like at that
point I'm no I'm not gonna go back to it
and like mm-hmm and weirdly like I don't
think after that they really ran into a
situation like that like the stuff they
did at after that was not that level of
crazy time ot like they did some of the
like the Kenley College assignments or
whatever and like I came back from that
a little bit and I think I missed
whatever the act to update was but I
think that was just like some missions
and it was a nine thing like super
Rangers so it was they never really ran
into that situation again and yet that
was the point where it just
kick me off the cliff and I just I
didn't come back after that really so
yeah for what it sounds like for loads
of New York it doesn't seem like at the
very least I can plan I'm assuming I can
play through the story campaign
perfectly normally with my existing
characters considering like they're
gonna let blank level 30 people knew it
and like I have at least some gear from
from way back when so I think I should
be mine if there's some crazy raid at
the ends like maybe that'll be a problem
again but it does seem to me like
they've learned that lesson
it's just that and it was so jarring
when it happened in the first place like
that was all I needed to just like peace
out and pace out and move out mm-hmm the
a great shot the slow-mo he said you
needed to have a specific bill when the
game was almost impossible to mid max
because they intentionally prevented God
rolls and they give three two linear
gear like in Division one and that that
was the consensus I heard from the
hardcore they were very very upset with
that aspect and you know they've gotta
fix I I'm kind of on a different side
from you II in a sense that I do like
the gear set aspect that they bring to
to to actually to armor and stuff and I
kind of wish destiny would steal that oh
yeah if there's certain things about it
I do love course you are right there
there's a ton of information there's a
ton of notion maybe there could be a
level of streamlining it to make you
know and I heard that's coming too
apparently with that that update wallets
in New York as well you know to get a
person like you II to say okay you know
this is a little bit more fluid this is
this is a UI that I can kind of attached
to like an old I've into a crazy amount
of stats have done that in other games
before it's just something about after a
while is this thing is having like you
know here's this magazine that's like
forty eight percent forty nine percent
fifty percent and it was every every
single thing had that on it it felt like
what we're so like whether it was the
armor every it was just everywhere and
it's not like it was consolidated in any
piece it was just like there was two
appointments like I don't mind stats too
that's why was like it was like I want
more I wants that's the matter more
bread it was just the fact that it was
like we have an issue of rolls of
randomness and destiny where there is
probably a different level of that in
Division of what you're trying to find
like if you're looking for a good role
as well so as always I don't know I've
haven't
play it that much that's why I kind of
let you guys that's this one a bit yeah
I've been a bit out of the game so yeah
but I was curious to see I was like okay
they're going back to New York this is
like inefficient 2.1 or something Oh
Mike I don't know what you call it yeah
but yeah it's definitely a way to go
back it was funny to see now is it a
one-to-one this time I heard or is it
just you reusing last time around no
that's a result that's a new zone it's
not reusing Division one stuff it's the
old map didn't go to lower Manhattan
it's stopped right it's no more so I'm
pretty sure it's almost all new yeah and
if it's one to one that was like that
seems kind of cool but it's again like
what is gonna keep me hooked on it and I
guess that's just what I'll have to see
because as you've all there's always so
many more than you're gonna have God
fall what does that one long yeah so I
mean that's Avengers is avenge I like
God fall off that's like a next-gen and
it's more just a little bit more fantasy
sci-fi but if it's a looter slash or
whatever they want to call these new
things now I don't know on titles
anymore but uh there's gonna be so many
if I'm just still shooting guns in
Manhattan maybe sometimes I just want to
escape to something a little crazier I
mean again that's just a preference on
what people want to play not not
knocking division cuz whatever like
division honestly is like all said it's
like for being a third person like
realistic cover shooter they do it well
like their cover system honestly after
playing gears division stepped all over
gears cover on it easily because I
didn't I mean the gears for me like
gears 5 was fine but like when I like
just the feel of the cover and like the
sticky and moving around division felt
good on cover and I will say like that
system somebody make sure you keep that
alive because their cover system has
been solid so there's certain things I
have enjoyed but it's just laying what's
gonna keep me going nothing
look look for me I'll finish up just
like you know I'm pulling for them I
want to see you know what happens I
think we were in this unique period with
destiny based on Bungie being on their
own based on the level of you know
frequency with the content stuff at
these these kind of gaps right so I
again I I think I don't want to say
that's these in trouble or anything
right I think
a perfect opportunity if any of these
games whether it be outriders whatever
you know I'm saying Division can anthem
can get their act together right because
we all agree with the seasonal model
there's gonna be some time for break for
the hardcore like us and this is where
they kind of swoop in and say hey we've
got this content going on right now
check us out and like definitely
currently right now I think it's
affording us the ability to actually
like Dessie the pass is a selfish game
destiny old-school deal want like you're
not you don't have time to be yours a
with shadow keep drive to take can drop
you don't have time to be grinding no
second lunar shooter so I think if
division is smart
you know said like this is the time we
try to do what your community one thing
and get people invested again so I'm
just gonna pay attention from you know
from a distance I'll jump in I see what
happened man I wish they had cross save
man I wish they had first plate like oh
like I want to be able to play on PC and
thing and it's very daunting to me
because I haven't really gone I all my
stuff is on my xbox 1x and it's not
daunting to start for them but they I
will give them credit they're doing a
destiny style onboarding where I believe
if you create a new character you're
automatically at 30 and then you can go
to 40 so they least do in that aspect
but in the future I really hope if they
on board I've been as far as a cross a
but stuff like they're not be a be
amazing yeah it doesn't it does have
that over just about all these because
just being able to hop on wherever is a
little really change yeah I play so much
more now that I can do SCN way more
absolutely yeah that's a game-changer a
lot of people have to learn from because
not every mean even if you have a ps4 -
PFF ps5 at different rooms for some of
these newer cross generation games like
I mean out writers and stuff like I'm at
my friend's house he's got a ps4 well
hey you should still get this and I can
come play with you or come over to mine
it looks fancier over here it's like
that switch is that's just gotta be a
more common thing but we've got to get
cross play so that's it everything
that's what I got on the competition I
mean we are wrapped we are coming right
up at on about two hours here so I do
owners neck falls time since we have yes
for a chunk this morning mmm
but sir I mean I want to definitely
thank you for coming again always
welcome pleasure to have you enjoy the
articles keep them going always a
pleasure to read them all believe me
yeah thanks right you're like it's it's
kind of a yep it's one of the best one
of the best policy in the building man
what you got going on man right now five
articles a day daily destiny column
spiff book in production we get some new
sci-fi novel flavor natural still
working at it but it's yeah it's a
sequel in my last book you're a killer
so another plea in the next record your
own audio books by the way I do not
record my own audio market forces way
better voices than me I could do you
just need to hire by few might be I'm
seriously considering that the sultry
sounds sounds familiar
oh I know what oh yeah oh yeah dude also
have you have been always a pleasure you
know you're welcome but I can't fight a
tee-time and this is a ton of fun love
picking your brain we love these looter
shooters and see anywhere these things
go and it's just fun it's always fun out
of these discussions just we're getting
saturated because there's only more
coming some will die you know
mouth-to-mouth resuscitation right now
but no Andy I'm with I'm with you II I
think at the end of the day read as much
as we complain about their city a bunch
of sometimes things aren't where they
are that core gameplay loop-the-loop
it's just something about it that it
just it just can't go away it just
they've they've got that base formula
that we just keep coming back and um
it'll be interesting to see you know
what the the competition does but I
still got faith that's they they're
gonna be fine hey they got trials coming
back so I'm completely biased right now
so it is that they could do no wrong cuz
long as it's like there's either flames
in the tower or everybody's hunky-dory
but I doubt it's gonna be it's probably
both actually but that's pretty much all
we got
quick outro kognito just keep it short
we will wrap this thing up yeah you
already know at low tide needle on
Twitter I'm a podcast on YouTube every
Sunday the Lord's Day big big guest this
Sunday please check us out at 1 p.m. we
have from kotaku news editor Jason
Schreyer don't come hang out with us
it's a it's gonna be a fun episode we're
gonna pick some brains we're gonna we're
gonna talk about development hell and
anthem stories and division stories and
just investigative reporting please the
support has been tremendous and of
course Lord gave me not nap thank you
guys so much you know you guys been
retweeting the articles you really
appreciate it and we as a result will be
media at PAX East I'm super pumped them
I'm hype about that start covering some
more games and um course every Friday
you know the best damn that's been
forecast we do last word many boxes
approaching 50,000 subscribers or
something like that right I bet you you
would like I broke 40 schools recently
and so I'm working on it hey you know we
gotta get this benefit too he's one of
the best in the game you know and salute
to my brother because what I love about
your content you always for the guy
who's not the hardcore guy you always
make it easy to unboard you're the own
boarding guy to help people I go to you
I'm like what's going on with these
árboles alright I watch the box the
video right man what am I supposed to be
doing and you do a fantastic job so
let's get e to 50 K he deserves it and
the other thing is we go get e we're
gonna get him down to one of those
Bungie summits and we're gonna get him
in there too that's that's the goal we
need his input in that so you could get
his armor 2.0 fix on that would be you
could push me over with a feather if I
ever got that advice so that's verified
that would be a dream but yeah thank you
guys for all the support lately for
listening here for listening on audio as
well it's on anchor it's on basically
every podcast platform but anchors are
hosts so they have been awesome so thank
you guys all for that one and thank you
all for just following liking respondent
to Paul's articles it's always good to
see the comments in there because yes
generally at this point it's nice just
to see the commentary over a topic that
we're all thinking about
it's always nice that he brings that
everybody's like forefront and then of
course please yes go listen to iron the
iron Lords podcast Jason Schreyer on
there is gonna be a great guest because
that is honestly if you've been paying
attention to gaming he's done some of
the best investigations that we've
probably ever seen so I'm very easy he's
the best journalist
yeah I'll say that I can a fanboy out
for video I really do this but like
obviously I've been doing concentrating
too long and and I looked at this week's
schedule and I'm like I got two of my
favorites it would like if you would
ever told me like yeah one day you're
gonna have you're gonna do a show at a
see it's Schreyer the same week I'm like
a baby baby I'm like so salute to you -
I don't want to undersell you - ban like
bro you are one of the best video game
journalists your passion for Luda
shooters show in everything you do and
you're one of the most approachable and
cool people that most people don't
realize that so salute to you brother
keep doing what you're doing we always
love you by the campfire and it's just a
great week so I'm very blessed to be
able to podcast with two people I really
respected but ya know that's honestly
amazing so yeah definitely listen to
that one guys and for all that you're
doing be it playing games just have fun
if you need a break from destiny take it
if you want to try something else take
it if you want to read an article about
three different games that top part
Paul's gonna write out every day read
them find a way to like enjoy your time
have fun and just do what you do what
you want to do there's so many freaking
games out there and console craziness
going on you're not gonna be bored just
find something you're having fun with so
we're gonna try this crazy outros we
always do so whenever I say it has been
we're all gonna try and say the last
word together but joys of editing I make
it match every time so can't really mess
it up but for everybody thank you guys
the show's been awesome chat has been
awesome thank you guys all as well for
being here live this is an episode 90
February 14th happy Valentine's to
everybody hopefully have an awesome one
and it has been
the last word